- It is time for tonight's #HashtagWars.
(audience cheers)
(buzzer rings)
Yes, Herzog.
- Mascot cannon.
You shoot the mascot into the stands.
(laughs)
(audience applause)
(buzzer rings)
- All right, points.
Doug Benson.
- Weed.
(audience laughs and cheers)
- That was such a daringly
cheap, pandering joke
I'm going to give you points for it.
- Yay!
(buzzer rings)
- [Chris] Arden.
- Little Shop of Hate Crimes.
- That would be an awful musical.
- [Arden] Yeah.
- Yes, points. (buzzer rings)
Dana.
- An American in Paris Hilton: Spermalot.
(laughs)
- Points.
(buzzer rings)
- [Chris] Michelle.
- Slip'N Slide into Oncoming Traffic.
- (laughs) Points. Very sad, yes indeed.
(buzzer rings)
Moshe Kasher.
- Dreidels.
- (laughs) What? You made it out of clay!
Points.
(buzzer rings)
Sean Patton.
- Mis-connect Four.
- (laughs) Points.
(buzzer rings)
Moshe.
- Tickle-Me Woody Allen.
- [Chris] Oh, man.
(laughs)
Points.
(buzzer rings)
- [Chris] Kurt.
- Law and Order: Special Discussion Unit
- (laughs) Points.
(buzzer rings)
James.
- Tattlestar Galactica.
- (laughs) Points.
(buzzer rings)
Neko.
- I just wanted to get a
buzz in. Just one buzz.
(audience laughs and cheers)
- Did you have an aftershow?
- Talk Salad and Scrambled
Eggs: The Frasier After Show.
- Yes, points!
Well done!
(energetic music)